- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is talk about what is often referred to as
the Bully Pulpit of the
United States President.
It's making reference to the idea
that the President has a platform
from which they can convince people,
that they can convey their own message.
There are explicit powers in
the United States Constitution
about what the President
can and cannot do,
but just as being that singular executive
at the top of the Executive Branch,
people are gonna pay
attention to what they say.
This term, bully pulpit, probably isn't
exactly what you imagine it to mean.
It actually comes to us
from Theodore Roosevelt,
that's a picture of Theodore
Roosevelt giving a speech.
He was president from 1901 to 1909.
He was actually the youngest person to
hold the office of President.
He took office when President
McKinley was assassinated,
and this is a quote from 1909,
from Lyman Abbott, who
wrote for "The Outlook".
"Half a dozen of us
were with the President,
Theodore Roosevelt, in his library.
He was sitting at his desk reading to us
his forthcoming message.
He had just finished reading a paragraph
of a distinctly ethical character
when he suddenly stopped,
swung round in his swivel chair and said,
'I suppose my critics
will call that preaching,
but I have got such a bully pulpit!'"
Theodore Roosevelt was famous for
using the term "bully" a lot,
and it doesn't mean to pick on people
in Theodore Roosevelt's context.
He used it as great, wonderful.
Bully for you, good for you.
When he said "a bully pulpit",
he's saying, "I have such a great platform
from which to speak."
He's not saying I have a platform
from which to pick on people.
And this was before mass media
became a significant
influence in politics.
At this time, recorded audio was
just starting to become a thing.
Television was not an
influence in politics.
But you can imagine,
once you have mass media,
especially radio, television,
and now social media
becoming a major factor,
this bully pulpit has only gotten
more and more and more significant.
One of the strongest
examples of Presidents
using their bully pulpit is
the State of the Union address.
State
of
the Union.
The Constitution does
call for the President
to make reports to Congress
on the state of the union,
but early Presidents,
like Thomas Jefferson,
just sent a written report.
But, eventually, over time, the President
started giving live reports to
the joint houses of Congress
in the form of a speech,
and then in 1947,
you have Truman's State
of the Union is televised.
Truman
televised.
Today, the State of the
Union is given every January,
this is a major event.
All the major networks show
it, the nation pays attention.
What Theodore Roosevelt was talking about
becomes even more powerful
for modern presidents
that have mass media at their disposal.
To get a good, tangible
sense of this power
that a President has, I'm gonna
show you a video from 1981.
This actually will not be a
State of the Union address.
This is an address that
President Reagan gives
to the nation on federal tax reduction.
Just so that you have context
on what the world was like,
or what the United
States was like, in 1981,
they had stagflation, a stagnant economy
with a lot of inflation
and high interest rates.
I remember, at the time, my mom had,
I think it was a 17% interest
rate on her mortgage,
which was incredibly, incredibly high.
What you're going to
see is President Reagan
making a direct plea
to the American people
to convince their representatives
to support his tax plan,
and think about what President
Reagan was able to do
that Thomas Jefferson, or
even Theodore Roosevelt,
could have only dreamed of.
- The best way to have a
strong foreign policy abroad
is to have a strong economy at home.
Now, the day after tomorrow, Wednesday,
the House of Representatives
will begin debate
on two tax bills, and once again,
they need to hear from you.
I know that doesn't give you much time,
but a great deal is at stake.
Let me add, those representatives
honestly and sincerely
want to know your feelings.
They get plenty of input from
the special interest groups.
They'd like to hear from their home folks.
Let me explain what the
situation is and what's at issue.
With our budget cuts, we
presented a complete program
of reduction in tax rates.
Again, our purpose was
to provide incentive
for the individual,
incentives for business
to encourage production and
hiring of the unemployed,
and to free up money for investment.
Our bill calls for a 5% reduction in
the income tax rates by October 1st,
a 10% reduction beginning July 1st, 1982,
and another 10% cut a year later.
A 25% total reduction over three years.
But then, to insure the
tax cut is permanent,
we call for indexing
the tax rates in 1985,
which means adjusting them for inflation.
As it is now, if you get
a cost of living raise
that's intended to keep
you even with inflation,
you find that the increase in
the number of dollars
you get may very likely
move you into a higher tax bracket,
and you wind up poorer than you were.
This is called bracket creep.
Bracket creep is an insidious tax.
Let me give an example.
If you earned $10,000 a year in 1972,
by 1980,
you had to earn $19,700
just to stay even with inflation,
but that's before taxes.
Come April 15th, you find your
tax rates have increased 30%.
Have you been wondering why you don't seem
as well off as you were a few years back?
It's because government
makes a profit on inflation.